if you want to better appreciate 1
Corinthians 14:
34-35 what it means and what it doesn't
mean then what we need to do is
see who the intended audience happens to
be and why Paul is even mentioning and
raising and addressing these issues all
right 1 Corinthians 14: 34-35 okay let's
read now let's see if you catch it let
your women keep silence in the churches
for it is not permitted unto them to
speak but they are commanded to be under
obedience as also sayith the law and if
they will learn anything let them ask
their husbands at home for it is a shame
for women to speak in the church I don't
know how many of you caught it even if
you want to take this passage to me
women cannot say anything at all in any
circumstance or
situation it's referring to a specific
group of women who caught it let's see
who catch it who's paying attention and
studying the scriptures this why you
guys got to read thank you Billy it's
talking to married woman
that means at most you're proving that
only married women should be silent not
unmarried ones so even this passage in
its context is not speaking of all kinds
of women it's speaking of a specific
group of women married ones so the most
this passage proves is that married
woman should be
silent so you guys are not reading
carefully so the most you prove from 1
Corinthians 14 3435 the most is only
married woman should be silent but even
then that's not his
point well syia it's not what you see
it's what the text says what does the
text say let them ask their husbands at
home so he's not talking
about all women or women in general
because women are not married who are
they going to ask because he's not
addressing that he was addressing
disruptive wives who are creating chaos
confusion and Division in the church
because they're promoting disorderly
conduct in the church
church because can you explain to me why
that comment was necessary that most
women were married when we just read in
1 Corinthians 7 there were many virgin
girls at that church who are not married
yet in 1 Corinthians 7 Lord Jesus have
mercy and forgive us all okay did you
guys remember in 1 Corinthians 7 Paul
was talking about virgin girls who are
betral to get married and he says to
those virgin girls that it's better they
don't get married in light of their
present crisis right so what point did
it serve for this tell me most women
were married is that he's addressing
married woman so he leaves the issue of
unmarried women open so right there
you're learning how not to interpret the
Bible and how to interpret the
Bible we're going to read now the
context now let's start 1 Corinthians 14
26 to 36 let's read read with me the
context how is it then brethren when you
come together every one of you have a
Psalm have a Doctrine every one of you
has a Psalm that they want to sing has a
teaching they want to share ha a tongue
they want to say something in a
particular language ha a revelation an
interpretation let all things be done
unto edifying make sure whatever you do
whatever you say it's to build up the
church strengthen the church in their
love for Jesus not tear down now pay
attention please if any man speak in an
unknown tongue Let It Be by two or at
the most
three and that by course meaning one at
a time and let one interpret it's got to
be interpreted so everyone understands
and benefits but if there be no
interpreter pay attention to the word
silence but if there be no interpreter
let him keep silence in the church I
want you please in Jesus name remember
this word silence it's the same word
used for
women okay same word used for
women in the church let him speak to
himself and to God now watch
here let the prophet speak to or three
if you have prophets want to Proclaim
two or three the most right two or three
the most right and let the other judge
if it's truly a prophetic word if
anything be revealed to another man
another that sth by let the first hold
his Peace So if a man during that time
is receiving Revelation right there from
the spirit the one Speaking be silent
let this man stand up and speak because
the spirit's prompting him to speak
okay for ye may all prophesy one by one
one at a time that all may learn and be
comforted okay now 32 and
33 and the spirits of the prophets are
subject to the prophets you have
control over that Revelation that
ecstatic speech it doesn't control you
because the holy spirit gives you the
strength to control it so you don't add
chaos and confusion but promote
unity and build up the body now notice
43 for God is not the author of
confusion but of Peace as in all
churches of the Saints you see what the
point is in the passage guys you
understand 33 is the key the point in
the passage is we want orderly worship
God is not a god of confusion he doesn't
cause people to speak out of turn speak
different languages that no one
understands so it's chaos in confusion
and no one gets built up he's not a god
of chaos of disorder he's a God of
Peace this is the
context this is the context for God is
not the author of confusion meaning
chaos disorder division that's what the
word means but of Peace of order of
unity let's read 3435 and we'll post it
one more time let your woman keep
silence in the churches for it is not
permitted un to them to speak but they
are commanded to be under obedience as
also sayith the law and if they will
learn anything let them ask their
husbands at home for it is a shame for
me to speak in the church what came the
word god out from you did it originate
from you or came it unto you only or are
you the only one that receives the word
of God is it clear what the context is
now is it clear what the context
is the context is about a church in
chaos and disorder people speaking out
of turns speak people speaking tongues
no one understanding women disrupting
the service by asking questions out of
turn and causing chaos and confusion
what's the point of Paul Paul is
addressing a specific
need plaguing a specific church at a
specific location in this church people
were speaking in tongues out of turn and
no one interpreting so that the rest
could not understand so they were not
being built up in this church people
were standing up and speaking out of
turn causing chaos confusion and no one
was being edified in this church there
were married
women married women speaking out of turn
asking questions adding to disruption
and confusion not promoting unity and
peace and understanding that's the
context now the word silence used
silence so Cindy gulian
notice what you said sounds like some of
the church you've been to that means now
1 Corinthians 14 applies to them though
is written to the Corinth it still has
meaning for us today because we still
need to follow that orderly structure of
worship so the whole Bible is for all
Christians in all generations until the
Lord returns but it was written to
specific communities with specific
needs see thank you Sharon de Cruz you
see now why 1 Corinthians 14 would apply
to your situation because unfortunately
nothing new Under the Sun and in every
generation of Christians we still have
carnal-minded infants or unbelievers and
sheep's clothing coming and creating
chaos bringing division destroying the
order of the church so 1 Corinthians 14
is still applicable and must be enforced
go and see that the
same Greek word
word used by Paul to say women be
silent okay be silent that same Greek
word right is used in verse 28 and 30
verses 28 and 30 so the same Greek word
SE
SE now let's read but if there be no
interpreter let him keep silence notice
what Paul is saying you speak in tongues
if no one interprets be silent same word
1 Corinthians 14:30 if anything be
revealed to another that sth but let the
first hold his peace let the first be
silent so the one who is prophesying be
silent and now what does it say about
the women let your women keep silence in
the churches see same thing you speaking
in tongues be silent if you don't have
someone interpreting you who happen to
be prophesying if someone receives a
revelation right there be silent let him
speak you marryed women be silent
now does this
mean that Paul is saying married woman
cannot contribute anything in the church
or is he
speaking in the context of married women
disrupting the
church and promoting chaos and confusion
and he says be silent don't ask a
question and disrupt the service ask
your husbands at home and they'll
clarify so Paul is no more forbidding
women from speaking as he's forbidding
prophets from prophesying as he's
forbidding people who speak in tongues
to speak in tongues publicly Paul is no
more forbidding married women from
speaking in the church as he's
preventing prophets from prophesying in
the church understand what the point is
now you understand what the point is now
now the point is there's a particular
group of married women causing
disruption and confusion in the church
at Corinth adding to chaos and confusion
as our prophets speaking out of turn and
one Prophet not respecting the other
Prophet who's receiving a fresh
Revelation at that moment by the spirit
to share and just sitting back and
letting that person speak or people
speaking in tongues without interpreting
and there for edifying no
one that's what he's address
addressing that women can pray and
prophesy in the church that married
woman married woman can pray and
prophesy in the church again is
confirmed by 1 Corinthians 11 are we
ready now for the icing of the cake to
settle this issue once and for all to
know what women can and cannot do in the
church that Paul in the same epistle
that same letter that same epistle shows
that married women can pray and prophesy
and therefore speak in the local body
and don't have to be
silent let's go to 1 Corinthians
11: 3 to10 the benefit of the doubt he's
essentially saying that in this
particular
scenario which is a woman speaking in
church and he'll elaborate on it more a
woman inherently has less of value to
offer than a man and thus it would
behoove her to just be quiet and defer
to the men in this scenario of course
not folks can I ask you a question does
God expect and
command married women to
pray or do married women not pray and
they just shut up sit there and be
mute is it the do of married women to
pray to God to sing to God to worship
God and to even teach specifically their
own
children if that's the case then 1
Corinthians 11 is clearly teaching women
who are married can pray and prophesy
like men husbands pray and prophesy and
their wives pray and prophesy so Paul is
not saying that women who are married
cannot pray cannot prophesy they must
pray and prophesy like men must pray and
prophesy and together they can pray and
prophesy but wait if that's what Paul is
saying then is Paul contradicting
himself in 1 Corinthians 14 when he says
married women remain silent in the
churches pay attention here Paul says
women who are married can pray and
prophesy as long as their head is
covered but then in 1 Corinthians 14:
34:35 says women be silent in the church
and ask your husbands is that a
contradiction because for a woman to
pray she can't be silent in the church
for a woman to prophesy prophesying the
Greek word means to proclaim proclaiming
the word of God how can she Proclaim
God's word in the church how can she
pray if she's to be altogether
silent so either
Paul is contradicting himself and for
married woman to pray and prophesy that
means they are speaking in the church
speaking aloud in mixed company in the
congregation so how can married women be
completely silent it was only to
specific women that were causing
disruption pay attention to this 1
Corinthians 7 vers1 pay attention folks
I need you to read this passage notice
what Paul says one more time now
concerning the things whereof ye wrote
unto me it is good for a man not to
touch a woman okay did you guys catch it
or did it go over our heads now
concerning the things whereof ye wrote
unto me it is good for a man not to
touch a woman do you see the context
Paul is saying you
Corinthians the church at Corinth wrote
to me a series of questions and now I'm
answering those questions and obviously
by inspiration of the holy spirit so you
see the point he's addressing questions
challenges issues plaguing a church at
that time at a location called
Corinth so if you don't understand that
he's responding to questions questions
of which we don't have but we can get an
idea and clue what those questions were
do any of you have that letter that the
Corinthians wrote to Paul with their
questions and issues and challenges does
anyone have
it does anyone have that list of
questions that
letter of course not so what does this
tell you off the bat what does this tell
you off the bat First Corinthians was
written to address the questions the
issues the concerns of a particular
Christian group living at a particular
time in a particular location therefore
1 Corinthians 1434
to35 right has an historical context
he's addressing a situation plaguing
that church at that time is that making
sense so when I want to understand what
1 Corinthians 14:34 and 35 is all about
I have to take into
consideration this this is addressing a
particular group of Christians a
particular group of women living in a
particular location at a particular time
and then once I properly understand his
point what he means and what he doesn't
mean then I can see how it applies to
Christians in the 21st century by the
power of the holy spirit for the glory
of Jesus Christ another example let's go
to 1 Corinthians 7:25 to 26 let's read 1
Corinthians 7:25 now concerning virgins
I have no commandment of the Lord yet I
give my judgment as one that hath
obtained mercy of the Lord to be
faithful I suppose therefore that this
is good for the present distress I say
that is good for a man so to be he's
addressing an issue that doesn't concern
us today necessarily he's addressing ing
an issue about whether virgins were
betro should be married off or should
they remain virgins and not get married
and then he says in light of your
present distress what
distress in light of your present crisis
the tribulation that you're undergoing
it's more fitting and better for you not
to get
married what distress what crisis
right what tribulation what virgins
you see this is not written to you is it
making sense 1 Corinthians 14: 34:35 is
not written to you it's written to those
Christians who had particular issues and
problems and he's addressing but it does
have meaning for us today for example
here's the principle you can extract
from
7226 if Christians are living in a time
where they're being persecuted
imprisoned tortured and killed and in
light of that it's easier for a
Christian not to get married because
when you get married it may add add to
the burden of remaining a faithful
witness to Christ because it's easier as
a single man to be willing to die for
Jesus than it is to be a father and a
husband and then have someone threaten
me that they're going to kill my
children before my eyes if I don't deny
Jesus so that's what Paul is saying in
light of your situation in light of your
crisis in light of your issues it's best
you don't get married because it'll be
easier for you to suffer tribulation and
endure persecution without caving into
temptation to deny the Lord Jesus
Christ so now this passage would have
meaning for Christians in China it would
be applicable for Christians in Iraq in
Syria who are being tortured imprisoned
beaten enslaved and or murdered or
rape and this is not the only time where
God spoke through an
inspired Emissary instructing
individuals in light of your situation
it's better you remain celibate and
single God told Jeremiah the very same
thing Jeremiah 16: 1-4 the word of
Jehovah came also unto me saying Thou
shalt not take thee a wife notice a
celibate Prophet so the word told
Jeremiah you will not take a wife
neither shalt thou have sons or
daughters in this place Jerusalem for
thus sayith Jehovah concerning the sons
and concerning the daughters that are
born in this place and concerning their
mothers that bear them right and
concerning their fathers that begat them
in this land they shall die of Grievous
deaths they shall not be lamented
neither shall they be buried but they
shall be as Dum upon the face of the
Earth and they shall be consumed by The
Sword and by famine and their carcasses
shall be meat for the fowls of heaven
and for the beasts of the earth you see
what God doing Jeremiah I'm going to
spare you the pain the
heartache because my people's sin are so
great I'm going to bring in Nations
headed by the king of Babylon to destroy
the city and the temple and Destroy its
inhabitants so I want to spare you from
the pain of seeing your wife and
children killed before your eyes or
dying of famine now does that mean this
instruction for Jeremiah or the
instruction that Paul gave to to the
Christians in Corinth that virgins don't
get married men remain celibate is
applicable for all Christians at all
times clear right if that is clear and
it makes sense we're going to re examine
1 Corinthians 14 34-35 again I hope this
is blessing you educating you helping
you understand the scriptures with
greater depth by the power of Holy
Spirit and appreciate more as we fall
more passionate with the Lord Jesus
Christ boy do I struggle with confidence
issues by the way honest confession you
may think I'm just saying it people
think I'm very confident and aggressive
like an alpha male no that's because the
Holy Spirit emboldens me and gives me
the grace to be bold for the glory of
Jesus outside of that boy